bonjour à tous alors il ya quelques
semaines on a parlé de ce qui n'osa et
du déterminisme et j'ai l'impression que
la doctrine espinosa re plaît
particulièrement
aujourd'hui le déterminisme est
considéré comme une sorte de postulats
comme une sorte d'évidence et bien
souvent quand on parle de liberté ou de
au libre arbitre
on est on est ramené à cette idée que ça
n'existe pas que tout ça n'est
qu'illusion que la liberté c'est cette
fiction créé par l'esprit main pour que
l'on puisse se persuader que l'on
choisit alors qu'en fait tout est
déterminé à l'extérieur de nous et nous
ne serions que les réceptacle passif de
notre environnement
face à cette doctrine va venir s'opposer
au 20e siècle la doctrine de jean paul
sartre on a comme une d'appeler
l'existentialisme est aujourd'hui dans
cette vidéo j'aimerais vous présenter ce
courant de pensée
alors peut-être quelques mots sur sartre
sartre est un philosophe écrivain
intellectuels français qui a beaucoup
marqué le xxème siècle notamment pour
son engagement politique
mais c'est vrai qu'on connaît moins le
sartre philosophe on pense plutôt aux
gens paul sartre militants on pense
également aux jean paul sartre écrivain
mais jean paul sartre nous a laissés
doctrine philosophique qu'il a un jour
pris le risque de résumer dans une
conférence qui s'appelait
l'existentialisme est un humanisme et
dans cette conférence il essaye à la
fois de présenter son courant de pensée
de la manière la plus accessible qui
soit et en même temps de répondre à
certaines questions notamment certaines
questions sur son orientation politique
le courant de l'existentialisme pourrait
se résumer dans cette célèbre citation
l'existence précède l'essence ça c'est
vraiment la citation qui résume le noyau
dur de la pensée existentialiste
l'existence précède l'essence
alors bien entendu dans cette vidéo on
va expliquer cette citation va expliquer
ce qu'elle veut dire mais avant ça je
vous propose de faire un petit détour
pour que l'on puisse entrer dans la
pensée de sartre par un autre chemin qui
va être le chemin de la croyance en dieu
jean paul sartre en est un intellectuel
hâter pour lui dieu n'existe pas c'est
une invention humaine et donc sa
philosophie se veut d'abord une
philosophie athée c'est une philosophie
qui ne présuppose pas ou qui n'implique
pas d'entités extérieures toute
puissante et créatrice et ça peut avoir
l'air de rien mais en fait c'est
vraiment fondateur c'est vraiment
structurant dans dans sa pensée
cette idée que l'homme n'a pas été créé
par dieu et s'il n'a pas été créé par
dieu au monde ici n'a pas de créateurs
et bien ça veut dire que l'existence
humaine n'a pas de sens
elle n'a pas de sens parce qu'elle n'est
pas le fruit d'une volonté elle n'est
pas le fruit d'une décision
et en ce sens il n'y a rien qui
définissent le sens de la vie en amont
de l'homme donc c'est une manière de
dire que l'homme est seul face à son
existence
il est seul face à la construction du
sens de son existence
donc on va retenir cette idée que
l'existentialisme de jean paul sartre
puisqu'il existe d'autres formes
d'existentialisme l'existentialisme de
sartre ne s'appuie sur aucune entité
divine aucune entité créatrice et ça ça
va avoir une importance capitale dans la
manière dont jean paul sartre va définir
l'existence humaine et c'est ce qu'il va
nous donner à comprendre dans sa
conférence
alors dans cette conférence sartre va
faire preuve d'une grande pédagogie
c'est à dire qu'il va nous donner des
exemples concrets
ainsi il va prendre l'exemple du coupe
papier le coupe-papier c'est un objet
dont la fonction est indiqué dans le nom
et sartre utilisent cet exemple pour
nous donner une illustration de ce
qu'est un objet créé le coupe-papier il
a été créé par la main de l'homme et il
a été créé dans le but de répondre à une
fonction donc ce qui définit les sens du
coup papier mais c'est sa fonction c'est
sa fonction qui est inscrite jusque dans
son nom et qui fait que cet objet va
avoir un sens il va s'inscrire dans un
réseau de sens où il aura une utilité
pour répondre à une certaine fonction
c'est ça qui va conférer le sens de
l'existence de cet objet alors que
l'homme n'ayant pas de créateurs l'homme
n'a donc pas de fonction il n'a pas de
sens son existence n'a pas de sens et ce
à partir de ce présupposé que jean paul
sartre va en déduire que l'essence de
l'homme on la construit
l'homme n'a pas d'essence parce qu'il
crée lui-même son essence pour sartre
l'homme est ce qu'il veut être l'homme
décide de ce qu'il veut être et c'est ça
vraiment le le point saillant de la
philosophie existentialiste de sartre
c'est l'idée que nous donnons nous mêmes
un sens à notre existence le sens que
nous donnons à notre existence
il n'est pas prêt défini par autre chose
que par nous-mêmes et bien entendu
sarthe prend en compte le fait que nous
sommes tous pris dans des environnements
qui vont nous influencer et ses
influences peuvent être considérés comme
de l'ordre du déterminisme à quoi on
échappe pas mais sauf que ça pour sartre
et on va y revenir c'est de la mauvaise
foi
en réalité l'homme fait comme si ils
étaient déterminés par des facteurs
extérieurs mais en réalité en faisant ça
l'homme se dissimulent à lui-même sa
propre lâcheté
mais ça on va y revenir dans quelques
instants et pour le moment j'aimerais
développer un peu sur cette conception
de la liberté chez sartre donc on l'a vu
parce que l'homme n'a pas été créé par
dieu c'est à l'homme de construire
lui-même le sens de son existence
et ça il le peut parce qu'il est le seul
être qui possède la liberté donc pour
sartre la liberté existe chez l'homme et
on peut même aller plus loin pour sartre
l'homme se définit par sa liberté
c'est à dire qu'il se définit par la
capacité qu'il a à chaque instant à
chaque seconde de sa vie de choisir de
choisir ce qu'il va faire et l'idée que
nous ne saurions que le produit d'un
contexte d'un environnement le produit
de détermination extérieur
st sartre le récuse totalement et il
fait même plus que le récuser il va
traiter de lâche et de [ __ ] ce qu'ils
nient cette liberté totale de l'homme et
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas totalement lui
donner tort parce que on n'en voudra
jamais à un animal par exemple d'avoir
tué un autre animal alors que ça n'était
pas nécessaire en lui en voudra pas
autant qu'un être humain parce qu'on
sait qu'ils existent dans l'être humain
la possibilité de dire non
la possibilité de s'arracher au
déterminisme physique
c'est l'idée qu'on attend un peu plus de
l'homme que des animaux on attend de
l'homme une capacité à dire non
une capacité à choisir et pour sartre si
l'homme est libre c'est parce qu'il
possède la conscience donc sartre va
totalement récusée la notion de
déterminisme historique telle qu'on la
retrouve chez hegel telle qu'on la
retrouve chez marx au contraire sartre
pense que l'homme est fondamentalement
libre et l'a d'ailleurs une phrase pour
le dire il dit l'homme est condamné à
être libres la liberté est un fardeau
dont on ne peut pas se déposséder la
liberté quelque chose qui est
consubstantielle à notre être à notre
essence parce que la seule essence de
l'homme selon sartre c'est sa liberté
c'est à dire le fait qu'il puisse
choisir son essence
l'homme se définit par sa liberté la
seule essence de l'homme que l'on peut
lui trouver
c'est sa liberté c'est-à-dire cette
capacité à construire son être à
construire son devenir et pour sartre
dire le contraire c'est de la mauvaise
foi
dire le contraire c'est de la lâcheté
dire le contraire c'est se mentir à
soi-même et s'est trouvé des excuses
pour pouvoir supporter le poids de la
culpabilité qui nous habite
en réalité nous savons que nous sommes
libres nous savons nous avons la
possibilité de choisir pour nous mêmes
ce que nous voulons mais on aime à se
dire enfermés dans un système d'habitude
on aime bien se dire que on ne peut pas
faire ce qu'on veut mais alors même qu
on fait ça pour sartre on est simplement
en train de se trouver des excuses
on est simplement en train de tisser un
voile d'illusions et un voile de
négation devant une réalité que nous ne
pouvons pas accepter d'assumer
parce qu'accepter une situation qui nous
rendent malheureux dure depuis un an
deux ans 5 ans 10 ans accepter ça et
avoir conscience qu'on l'acceptent c'est
quelque chose que la conscience humaine
n'est pas prête à supporter c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup trop lourde
beaucoup trop pesant et on préfère à
toujours se dire que si on en est là
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas une chance
c'est parce qu'on a fait des mauvaises
rencontres
c'est parce qu'il nous est arrivé des
choses qui ne dépendrait pas de nous et
on aura bien évidemment raison de le
dire il y aura forcément des choses qui
auront joué en notre défaveur sans qu'il
ne soit possible de faire autrement
bien sûr pour sartre il existe une part
d'inéluctable mais selon lui ça ne doit
pas nous rendre aveugle à notre propre
pouvoir à notre propre influence à notre
propre maîtrise de notre vie de ce que
nous voulons être du sens que nous
donnons à notre existence
et là encore sartre va nous donner un
exemple extrêmement concret c'est
l'exemple du garçon de café alors le
garçon café c'est un individu qui tous
les matins se rend sur son lieu de
travail qui va enfiler son costume de
garçons de café et qui pendant tout son
service va jouer son rôle il va jouer
son rôle de garçon de café qui est le
rôle pour lequel il est là et pour
lequel on le paye donc a priori rien
d'extraordinaire là dedans mais ce que
nous dit sartre c'est que lorsque cet
être humain
on va appeler jean jacques lorsque
jean-jacques est en train d'effectuer
son service en tant que garçon de café
il oublie qu'il est jean jacques il
oublie qu'il est quelqu'un sous le
costume sous ce rôle qu'il joue le rôle
social qu'il est obligé de jouer parce
que nous jouons tous un rôle social et
jean-jacques comme n'importe qui n'a pas
forcément conscience au moment où il
joue ce rôle d'être en train de jouer un
rôle
jean-jacques il oublie qu'il est
jean-jacques derrière le garçon de café
il oublie qu'il est un être humain doté
d'une conscience doté d'un libre arbitre
derrière le rôle social qu'il est en
train de jouer ils oublient que ce n'est
pas parce qu'on porte un costume que
l'on est obligé de vendre notre liberté
si jean-jacques décide de retirer son
tablier en réalité rien ne pourra l'en
empêcher il aura pris sa décision et à
moins de le contraindre physiquement
s'il a pris sa décision
personne ne pourra l'empêcher mais ça
pourrait presque être la devise de
l'existentialisme de sartre la devise de
la liberté qu'est ce qui t'empêche c'est
ça la question que tu dois te poser
qu'est ce qui n'empêche pas ce que c'est
la seule question qui a du sens pour toi
c'est la seule question qui a du sens
parce que le sens ne peut provenir que
de toi même le sens ne sera pas donnée
par une autorité extérieure
qu'est ce qui te n'empêche ça veut dire
quand tu penses que c'est la bonne
décision prend là parce que si tu ne la
prend pas qui va tomber dans le regret
et tu vas t'en vouloir tu vas donc
également tombé dans la culpabilité et
c'est d'ailleurs ça le risque de cette
liberté chez sartre c'est le revers de
la médaille c'est ce qu'elle implique
en retour à savoir la responsabilité et
à une liberté totale correspond une
responsabilité totale
donc si je n'utilise pas ma liberté je
suis responsable de ne pas l'avoir
utilisé si je l'utilisent à mauvais
escient
je suis également responsable de l'avoir
utilisé à mauvais escient ce qui fait
que je suis toujours tout le temps
responsable et c'est parce que je suis
entièrement libre que je suis
entièrement responsable responsable non
seulement de ce que je fais mais aussi
de ce qui existe de tout ce qui existe
sur terre de tout ce qui existe dans le
monde parce que tout ce qui existe
existe du seul fait que je le laisse
existait du seul fait que je
n'interviens pas pour modifier les
choses
et ça ça peut conduire un sentiment de
culpabilité ça peut conduire à l'idée
qu'on ne fait pas suffisamment de choses
ou qu'on n'agit pas conformément à nos
valeurs et à nos idéaux prétendu ça peut
amener beaucoup de culpabilité mais pour
sartre cette culpabilité elle est
nécessaire pour comprendre
elle est nécessaire pour comprendre que
nous sommes entièrement libres que nous
sommes condamnés à être libre et qu'à
chaque fois qu'on refuse d'assumer cette
liberté c'est-à-dire que l'on refuse
d'assumer de faire des choix on tombe
alors dans la mauvaise foi on tombe
alors dans la lâcheté
on tombe dans le mensonge à soi parce
que ça c'est vraiment une idée sur
laquelle j'ai envie d'insister c'est
l'idée que nous n'existons que parce que
nous faisons nous n'existons que par nos
actions et tout le reste n'est que
constructions virtuelles tout le reste
n'est que de la poudre
la seule essence de l'homme et en la
liberté à chaque fois que l'on refuse
cette liberté à chaque fois que l'on
s'enferme dans la mauvaise foi dans la
lâcheté dans le mensonge à soi or ni la
part humaine qui est en nous ont remis
ce qui fait la spécificité de notre être
c'est à dire la possibilité de le
choisir et bien sûr que c'est
extrêmement risqué de choisir parce que
lorsqu'on choisit on sait que l'on a
laissé échapper une option avec
l'impossibilité de savoir si cette
option était la bonne ou pas donc le
choix est toujours un pari
un choix toujours un pari parce qu'il
nous est impossible de faire un choix en
possédant tous les facteurs mais la
question n'est pas de savoir si on
possède tous les facteurs aussi même il
est possible de connaître tous les
facteurs la question de savoir qu'est ce
qu'on veut est-ce qu'on veut continuer à
être ou est ce qu on veut exister
exister c'est un petit peu différent
c'est heidegger qui disait que les
choses étaient mais que les hommes
existait l'homme existe parce qu'il a
conscience d'aller vers la mort est donc
sacré en lui un rapport particulier à
l'existence la conscience que bientôt
nous ne serons plus rien et le
questionnement qui découle de cette
réalité donc existe m c'est le privilège
d être conscient et les êtres conscients
savent qu'ils sont eux-mêmes leur propre
jugement
vous savez on cite souvent cette phrase
de jean-paul sartre l'enfer c'est les
autres
l'enfer c'est les autres c'est une
citation qui conclut sa pièce de théâtre
huis clos et qui consistait à dire
grossièrement que la culpabilité c'est
l'intériorisation en soi du jugement de
l'autre et le problème que nous avons
tous c'est que nous prenons en compte le
jugement de l'autre nous accordons une
part de vrai au jugement de l'autre on
et c'est cette impossibilité de se
détacher d'autrui cette impossibilité de
nier l'existence d'autrui qui fait que
nous sommes dans l'enfer du jugement
mais pour sartre le seul juge de nous
mêmes c'est nous mêmes la seule personne
à laquelle on va devoir rendre des
comptes c'est nous mêmes donc c'est
toujours à nous mêmes que nous nous
devons d'être libre est ce que tu veux
avoir le même destin que le coupe-papier
dont la fonction est inscrite dans le
nom c'est ça que veut nous dire sartre
quel est ce stade de la déshumanisation
tels que nous acceptons de n'être que
des rôles à jouer de n'être que des
personnages quelle est cette humanité
qui refuse de considérer la seule chose
qui la définissent à savoir sa liberté
j'ai terminé cette vidéo sur le récit
d'une petite anecdote puis direz vous
que j'ai revu le documentaire de pierre
carles
attention danger travail et dans ce
petit documentaire on assiste au
processus de recrutement d'une équipe de
livreurs à domino's pizza et c'est très
intéressant parce que carla a ce talent
de réalisateur
sa manière de filmer fait qu on est en
totale immersion on a vraiment la
sensation d'être dans la scène de sentir
les vibrations et dans ce documentaire
on voit ce qu'est le le processus de
déshumanisation le processus de
réunification qui fait que l'être humain
qui possède une conscience et donc une
liberté va devenir un personnage va
devenir un rôle auquel on va imposer un
système de normes auxquelles on va
imposer en costume une casquette manière
de porter la barbe et on va dire à cet
être humain que l'on sait être un être
humain à partir de maintenant tu n'es
plus jean-jacques partir de maintenant
tu es un rouage de la machine partir de
maintenant tu es une pièce de cette
machine un peu comme ce philosophe
louche
dans midnight express qui essaye de
faire comprendre aux héros que les
détenus sont les pièces défectueuses de
la machine ce qui suppose que quelqu'un
sache comment fonctionne la machine peut
être que quelqu'un ait créé la machine
pour sa personne n'a créé la machine et
donc nous n'avons pas à nous conduire
comme si nous étions les pièces d'une
machine ne vont pas nous conduire comme
si nous étions désarmés nous sommes pas
désarmé nous avons tous une arme qui
notre liberté
c'est une arme qui peut se retourner
contre son propriétaire
si elle est mal utilisée parce que si la
liberté est une arme
la responsabilité c'est la blessure
qu'elle nous inflige et la
responsabilité
nous savons en nous mêmes que nous ne
pourrons jamais l'attribué à quelqu'un
d'autre que nous pourrons jamais rejeter
la faute sur les autres
nous le savons donc quand les choses
vous paraîtront impossible à réaliser
trop utopique trop ambitieuse trop haut
vol
posez-vous simplement cette question
qu'est ce qui t'a en empêche
[Musique]
et
oh